[Música]
las autoridades de Ucrania alertan de
nuevos ataques rusos sobre gerson la
ciudad que las tropas de Moscú
abandonaron hace dos semanas el ejército
ruso mantiene la ofensiva contra la red
energética de Ucrania y gran parte del
territorio no dispone de suministros
básicos
hoy 25 de noviembre se conmemora el día
de la eliminación de la violencia contra
las mujeres y las niñas según la
Organización Mundial de la Salud
aproximadamente una de cada tres mujeres
en todo el mundo sufre violencia física
y sexual
el presidente de Perú Pedro Castillo
renovará su gabinete de ministros tras
confirmar la renuncia del Primer
Ministro Aníbal Torres luego de que la
mesa directiva del Congreso rechazara
una cuestión de confianza que hizo la
semana pasada Tenemos reporte de nuestro
corresponsal
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de Franz 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mateu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
empezamos esta edición con información
relativa a la guerra en Ucrania porque
Rusia mantiene y eleva su ofensiva
contra la red energética ucraniana como
consecuencia gran parte del territorio
permanece sin acceso a suministros
básicos por otro lado las autoridades
ucranianas evacúan el hospital de gerson
debido a los constantes bombardeos rusos
recordemos que el ejército de Moscú
abandonó la ciudad el pasado 9 de
noviembre y que desde entonces ha sido
recuperada por las fuerzas de kiev Sin
embargo las tropas rusas permanecen a
escasos kilómetros justo del otro lado
del río nieper y Desde esa posición
continúan atacando la urbe ataques que
mataron ayer a 9 personas nuestra
enviada especial Catalina Gómez Ángel no
reporta desde kiev la situación en la
ciudad de gerson se deteriora con horas
como ya lo había anunciado en su
intervención de la noche de ayer el
presidente bolodomir selensky el número
de misiles que caen sobre la ciudad cada
vez son mayor ayer por ejemplo en uno de
los distritos cercanos a la estación de
tren donde todos los días llegan cientos
de personas tratando de dejar la ciudad
cayó uno de estos misiles dejó cinco
personas muertos esto solamente en la
noche y estamos en una de las plazoletas
a la entrada de la ciudad Esta es
absolutamente necesaria pasar por aquí
cuando se viene de la ciudad de Nicolás
y aquí también está muy cerca el
supermercado la única gran superficie
abierta en la ciudad de que desde días
atrás provee de alimentos a los
habitantes de gersor hemos visto en las
últimas vías filas y filas de personas
esperando acceder a productos básicos Y
aquí mismo cayeron estos dos misiles uno
en el medio de la plazoleta otro en un
edificio cercano donde estos es bomberos
integrantes de Los cuerpos de seguridad
de personas están tratando de desminar y
Desactivar Así que la situación cada vez
es más complicada y de allí que cientos
de personas en las últimas horas
empiecen a abandonar a Jesús ya no lo
hacen por la falta de Electricidad o por
la falta de agua o la escasez de
calefacción ahora que hace tanto frío
sino por esos ataques continuos que como
queda demostrado tienen como objetos
cercanías donde está la población civil
y en Reino Unido en medio de una crisis
social histórica el sindicato de
enfermería anunció una huelga inédita
para exigir aumentos salariales y
mejoras laborales se trata de su primera
acción sindical en décadas que se da en
medio de una caída de un 20% en sus
salarios veamos más en el siguiente
informe de amalvenorman una medida que
no se ha visto en 106 años y que ilustra
la gravedad de la crisis social Reino
Unido por primera vez en su historia el
sindicato de enfermeros del país decidió
ir a huelga los días 15 y 20 de
diciembre después de que el gobierno se
negara a aceptar su petición de un
aumento salarial
llevamos más de una década sin aumento
de salario y los enfermeros trabajan muy
duro así que no se trata solo de
aplaudirnos durante la pandemia creo que
debemos respetados y apreciados por lo
que hacemos según las estimaciones los
salarios de los enfermeros y enfermeras
han caído unos 20% desde 2010 en parte
debido a la actual crisis del coste de
la vida con una inflación superior al
11%. el salario anual de una enfermero
principiante ronda los 27.000 libras
unos
32.500 dólares estadounidenses por lo
que uno de cada cuatro hospitales creó
bancos de alimentos para apoyar al
personal pero el gobierno alega que es
un momento difícil para todos y que no
puedes satisfacer las demandas
creo que el gobierno tiene que escuchar
de verdad Esto no es algo que las
enfermeras hagan impulsivamente es algo
que el personal de enfermería nunca ha
hecho en todo Reino Unido en tan gran
número Así que significativo y deberían
ver un mensaje muy claro al gobierno de
que tiene que hacer algo
la huelga se produce en un momento en el
que el sistema de salud pública que
lleva años sin financiación suficiente
atraviesa una profunda crisis pero el
descontento no se limita al sector
sanitario muchos otros empleados de los
sectores públicos y privado desde
abogados hasta el personal de los
aeropuertos e incluso los carteros
también han ido a huelga este año
y en el marco del día internacional de
la eliminación de la violencia contra
las mujeres recordamos la situación de
las niñas las jóvenes y las mujeres
adultas de Afganistán que viven bajo una
opresión de género agravada desde que
los talibanes retomaron el poder hace
más de un año veamos el informe
Marian tenía la esperanza de convertirse
médica su padre siempre había alentado
sus estudios Pero todo cambió cuando los
talibanes volvieron al poder
nunca había pensado que llegaría un día
en el que no podríamos estudiar más en
el que no podríamos alcanzar nuestros
sueños en lugar de estudiar ahora lavó
los platos lavo la ropa y friego el
suelo todo esto es muy duro
con su salario reducido a casi la mitad
bajo el régimen talibán el padre de
Marian sintió que no podía rechazar a
los posibles pretendientes de sus hijas
cada vez que venían decían que yo no le
daría la mano a mis hijas mi intención
era que terminaran la universidad
después de marzo cuando no se permitió a
las niñas ir a la escuela vi que los
talibanes no iban a dar Un paso atrás
después de eso cuando llegó la propuesta
le dije a mariam que mi experiencia
anterior con los talibanes me dice que
no van a dar marcha atrás
una mezcla de crisis económica y valores
patriarcales muy arraigados hace que las
jóvenes de Afganistán compartan el
destino de Mariano cuando los talibanes
retomaron el control del año pasado hubo
una breve esperanza de que permitirían
más a las mujeres en comparación con su
gobierno de la década de 1990 pero la
reapertura prevista de las escuelas
secundarias para niñas en marzo fue
cancelada y las restricciones a las
mujeres se ha multiplicado la economía
afgana dependiente de la ayuda también
se ha hundido desde la toma del poder
dejando a la mitad de sus 38 millones de
habitantes con hambre las hermanas Sara
y Fátima se quedaron sin poder graduarse
de la escuela secundaria y presentarse a
los exámenes de acceso a la universidad
después de que su padre el sostén de la
familia muriera de Kobe 19 decidieron
que había que empezar a buscar marido
estamos obligadas a casarnos porque es
mejor casarse que ser una carga para
nuestra familia habíamos planeado
continuar con nuestros estudios Pero
ahora no hay esperanza de continuar con
nuestra educación los expertos dicen que
la educación no solo es fundamental para
retrasar el matrimonio de las niñas sino
también la maternidad que conlleva una
mayor tasa de mortalidad infantil y
maternidad a una edad temprana
en noticias del mundial de Qatar Neymar
no jugará el próximo partido de la
Selección de Brasil tras sufrir una
lesión en el tobillo derecho por otro
lado iraní gales inauguraron la segunda
Ronda de encuentros de la primera fase
el partido se selló con Victoria de 2 a
0 para los persas con goles en los
últimos minutos del encuentro a
diferencia de en su primer partido esta
vez los jugadores de la selección iraní
si cantaron su Himno Nacional sin
embargo las protestas contra el gobierno
de la República islámica estuvieron
presentes en la gradería un hombre
vestido con una camiseta con el eslogan
mujer vida y libertad fue sacado del
estadio por las autoridades de Qatar
y en otras noticias del mundial ex
compañeros de Diego Armando Maradona le
rindieron homenaje en el día en que se
cumplen dos años de su muerte
considerado uno de los mejores
futbolistas de la historia El argentino
murió a los 60 años el 25 de noviembre
de 2020 Y a esta hora continúa abierto
el caso contra 8 personas de su equipo
médico por posible negligencia el Astro
del fútbol fue una figura estrechamente
vinculada al socialismo y al ante
imperialismo de Estados Unidos sin
embargo también fue acusado de violencia
machista y abuso de menores dos años
después de su muerte el mito de Maradona
vive en la memoria de los aficionados
del fútbol así lo recordó el presidente
de la conmebol
y él no podía faltar en este mundial por
eso está con nosotros aquí presente y
siempre va a estar en cada uno de todos
los corazones de los que amamos el
fútbol de buena manera así que muchas
gracias
al cielo para Diego en otras noticias en
China los principales dirigentes del
país recibieron al presidente de Cuba
Miguel Díaz canel quien realiza una gira
internacional para afianzar las
relaciones económicas con varias
naciones amigas antes de llegar a China
el mandatario cubano pasó por Argelia
Rusia y Turquía Rafael Pérez nos cuenta
más
una gira clave y necesaria en un
contexto económico complejo el
presidente cubano fue recibido en China
por su homólogo en la última parada de
su periplo internacional
Beijing es uno de los principales
aliados de La Habana por lo que la
visita Tuvo una connotación
principalmente económica y simbólica el
señor presidente es el primer jefe de
estado de los países de América Latina y
el Caribe que visita china después del
vigésimo Congreso Nacional del partido
comunista Chino lo que refleja la
especial relación amistosa entre las dos
naciones
anteriormente el jefe de estado caribeño
sostuvo un encuentro en Turquía con el
presidente
receptayberdoan evaluamos las
oportunidades para desarrollar la
cooperación existente en Campos como la
energía del turismo la construcción la
agricultura el desarrollo la salud y el
medio ambiente
arquelia y Rusia también fueron parte
del trayecto la cancelación de los
servicios de la deuda de laplazamiento
de su pago fue una de las decisiones más
importantes de su visita argel y el paso
por Rusia reforzó la unión de ambos
países en un frente común
le hacemos en un momento en que ambos
países ambas naciones tanto Rusia como
Cuba están sometidas a sanciones
injustas arbitrarias que proceden y
tienen su origen el mismo enemigo el
Imperio Yankee ha manipulado también a
una parte importante
regresará Turquía allí sostendrá un
encuentro con varios empresarios turcos
antes de retornar a la Habana
Hablamos ahora de Colombia porque la
sala de reconocimiento de la
jurisdicción especial para la paz emitió
su primera resolución de conclusiones
finales tras varios años de abrirse el
caso por secuestros cometidos por la ex
guerrilla de las FARC concluye que los
comandantes del antiguo secretariado de
las FARC cumplieron con entregar la
verdad Pero solicita que los líderes de
la extinta guerrilla paguen entre 5 y 8
años de sanciones reparadoras la sala
recomienda que los excomandantes paguen
los crímenes con proyectos de
recuperación ambiental acciones de
memoria con trabajos de determinado y
búsqueda de desaparecidos la decisión
final la tomará sin embargo el tribunal
de paz que también debe pronunciarse
sobre el futuro de los ex comandantes en
términos de participación política
en Perú el presidente Pedro Castillo
anunció la renovación del gabinete tras
la renuncia de su Primer Ministro Aníbal
Torres nuestro corresponsal Francisco
Zacarías nos habló de lo que representa
para el mandatario este escenario
representa una doble derrota política
para el mandatario peruano Porque tanto
el tribunal constitucional como el
congreso de este país le dijeron a Pedro
Castillo que su gobierno no puede
modificar una ley porque eso es trabajo
exclusivo del parlamento qué es lo que
había sucedido la mesa directiva del
Congreso de Perú declaró inadmisible la
cuestión de confianza planteada hace una
semana por el hasta ayer Primer Ministro
Aníbal Torres para modificar la ley del
referéndum muchos legisladores
consideran que la medida Busca en el
fondo impulsar un referéndum para
modificar la Constitución peruana y esto
a su vez permitiese a Pedro Castillo
evadir a la justicia por las seis
acusaciones que tiene en su contra por
presunta y lo legisladores también temen
que al modificarse de la Carta Magna
peruana Pedro Castillo podría intentar
quedarse más de los cinco años
establecidos por la Constitución
Política de este país pues bien en este
hecho que de poderes entre el poder
legislativo y el poder ejecutivo al ser
declarada inadmisible la cuestión de
confianza Aníbal Torres renunció y a
Pedro Castillo no le quedó más remedio
que aceptar la derrota y la renuncia de
su Primer Ministro
Muchísimas gracias por su atención
pueden ampliar esta y más información en
France 24 y France 24.com enseguida
volvemos
[Música]